[Music]
al your boy
six nine get the [ __ ] out your boy six
is causing some ruckus yeah i didn't
break this down i didn't understand what
happened i read these tweets and i
didn't get it
so it's more of his fake capping so
basically he
i don't know how he knew but meek mill's
at some restaurant he goes waits outside
for him to come out
he has his bodyguards with him meek
comes out with his bodyguards with him
everybody knows that neither one of them
are gonna fight but they're all just
talking josh and both sides have their
phone out
so they're recording them just cursing
at one another while the [ __ ]
bodyguards are in between both of them
there's some [ __ ] i would
like meek mill claims he spit on him i
didn't really see it
six nines claims that meek mill's
running with police as his security or
whatever the case is but it was just
who was takashi to judge anybody for
rolling with police
some that's why this whole thing was so
isn't he a witness [ __ ] protection
yeah no not anymore oh no he was you
were at one point in your life and
witness protection
so you can't knock anybody having police
security that's what it's doing who the
[ __ ] else supposed to secure you
you can that's why people feel safe all
the time please secure them
nada you can't knock people with
security if they
are claiming they're gangster is me
still doing that yeah
yeah all reformed no he like half in
half
what restaurant he was eating at
probably wasn't a [ __ ] mcdonald's
damn i don't know the restaurant
probably wasn't getting chicken tenders
he might have got chicken tenders bro he
might have got some jiggers he might
have got something
dude he might have some jiggly than this
what do you think you got some jiggity
[Laughter]
cutlets
yeah dude sometimes you got to get a
little jiggly bone
you got a good little jiggy bar
um but nah this is an interesting one
because i don't know if this
is i doubt this is this is meek mill
being like actively involved in this but
maybe six nine is just searching for a
rapper dumb enough to beef with him
yeah yeah like i think again i don't
know all these [ __ ] but like i
think
little dirk kind of like brilliantly
just said i'm not gonna
deal with this guy at all i'm not gonna
beef with this guy at all right yeah and
then
he didn't beef with him six nine's album
flops right
dirk puts out an album later and it
looks initially like it's not gonna do
that well
but then if it was apparently only one
day's sales
and then he's been killing it with this
[ __ ] album yeah and
so like dirk kind of figured out the
best way to handle six nine six nine is
a sale
yeah sales need wind yeah sales can do
nothing by themselves yeah they just
stand there the second there's
wind all of a sudden you are moving yeah
right
so six nine knows he needs beef that's
his wind
right so he's like is there a rapper
that's dumb enough that's actually gonna
engage with me
maybe a rapper that kind of needs some
attention meek's been falling off the
music hasn't really been there i mean
has he had like a hit recently
not really not really you know so
i wonder if he's like all right let me
see if i can cook something up with meek
i need some attention
i think uh he's trying to drop a new
song he leaked a little something on his
instagram
did he drop it yet i don't know if he
dropped it but he definitely showed like
a little preview of two new songs so
he's trying to tap into the beef thing
so he can do it he's also like what's
the safest guy to beef with i can't beat
with one of these real street
[ __ ] because they ain't gonna
kill my ass
right but i can beef with one of these
reform thugs who feels like they still
gotta protect themselves
protect their gangster and show that
they got it but at the same time they're
like i ain't going back to jail and he
knows he's on parole so
oh meek is on parole he can't do nothing
he's finding the perfect person that
can't do [ __ ] that he can make look like
a [ __ ]
yeah he gonna talk all that [ __ ] make
him look like a [ __ ]
and me can't do anything back or else
he's going back to jail and mick does
not want to do that no more
yeah i mean bro this is kind of corny
dude
i was telling mark the other day it's
over for six night man it really
is and it's a shame because he was so
funny bro
like when he was just doing funny stuff
remember like running in the hotels or
like
playing goalie and soccer like he would
do some really funny skits like he's a
funny kid
yeah you know that like he edits all his
own music videos i think you were
telling me this yeah like so he comes
from this
as like an editor like creative
and then he goes okay how do i put
together a character that will work and
i'll sell this music but
he's a kind of nerd yeah and they just
figured it out
i mean it's it's such a bummer man it is
such a bummer he was a really
entertaining character but yeah if
nobody's gonna engage with him with the
beef
and he doesn't have credibility to beef
cause
before when he was claiming super thug
you gotta react to a super thug if
you're a super thug
yeah right now when everybody knows
you're not
and that you snitched and now you rode
the cops you'll gotta react to that
person exactly
because that person can't pull your card
at all yeah if six nine calls gucci a
[ __ ]
gucci gotta go oh i don't talk to the
police yeah yeah he don't have to beef
back
if who's a real street dude if little
dirk calls gucci a [ __ ]
gucci got to say something right
interesting yeah i don't know man so
what does he do next
oh
i think he has to pivot the music
whereas like he could try to find a
balance between like that
aggressive [ __ ] but with lighter
content like he's still trying to act
tough in his music
yeah because his music is just
aggressive like how do you talk about a
happy subject but it's like he has to
try to find that medium because
nobody believes you anymore with the
tough guy [ __ ] yeah
but all he really knows how to make is
the tough guy
well we'll see who knows who knows what
happens next but uh anything else
anything else you want to talk about i
think that's it i think we hit it
yeah oh halle berry do you care
you